This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina
sounds funny.
It actually that part down.
So funny.
Now
his scream and stuff.
Do you want to know what the name of that song is?
It's called.
How do you not find that funny by Alan Bell?
That's great.
Yeah.
It's funny cause I don't see him right now.
I don't see that he's suffering so I can just laugh at the sounds that he's
making,
right?
Yeah,
it's good stuff,
right?
It's a really good
talent.
Openness.
All M Jeezy what's going on Thomas?
Oris we are still,
um,
so people know we're both sick.
It's nice.
I know.
I've been sick for like two months.
I feel like I,
it's hard to shake it.
So annoying.
Cause our kids always sick and then you get whatever preschool disease he brings
home when he gets sick every other week.
I know.
And now there's foot and mouth going around his preschool today when I dropped
him off and I almost hesitated and then I'm like,
you know what?
He's going to need to get that.
Eventually.
Every kid gets some,
but I did.
They have that shit when we were kids.
Hand,
foot and mouth disease.
I feel like it doesn't sound familiar from that era and then we're hearing it
later.
Yeah.
I feel like this is a recent thing.
You and I aren't really sure what it is.
We had chicken pox.
That was our generation.
We do have chicken pox.
You got chicken pox and you can find scabs on your head.
Yeah.
It was the best ones because you could pick those.
Really,
really scrape at him.
Yeah.
Who cares if you get a scar on your head and you'll find some blood in there.
You're like,
oh,
this is all those oatmeal baths.
They smell delicious.
They sure do.
Thanks everybody.
A lot of people enjoy Johnny Pemberton's episode.
How funny is he?
He's great and his accents were amazing.
Master.
I don't know about that.
Let's not get crazy.
He's really good.
Hey Tom,
if there's only one master and that's you.
Thanks a lot.
Dogs by
wow.
What?
What region was that was east London.
Wow.
You are so down to the,
just to the actual neighborhoods.
What else have you been working on accent wise?
Um,
I know you're watching that Winston Churchill movie.
Did you pick up any inspiration from there?
Uh,
I mean,
you know,
I've been doing that,
those dialects for a long time.
I'm trying to actually move out of the whole United Kingdom cause too easy.
So I've been trying to go to like other parts of the world,
you know.
What are you,
where are you looking?
Um,
there are some Baltic stuff that I've been working on.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
so like an example,
it'd be like a
good,
so that would be wow.
Yeah.
Well I mean you sounded just like a relative.
I could have like an 80 year old man in a small village.
Wow.
And you know,
honestly I was working with my dialect coach other day and he was like,
you picked that up immediately.
You don't even have to try it.
You have such a finely tuned ear.
Where do you practice?
I've never seen you practice.
Right.
And come in here and pitch perfect.
I designed to the studio because we had the,
the good fortune of having a musician here before us.
So both are using our instruments.
I saw some interview you did,
um,
on youtube and you were like,
oh,
we have a professional studio.
The guy that used to score,
you know,
movies and now we talk about farts in there.
So it's kind of neat.
He would really wasn't accomplished guy.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And he had big time artists in here.
I know.
Now we're like,
you can't just drink home.
You got to wash your face with it too.
Yeah.
So stick.
Hang.
Yeah.
Well let's get our stupidity going.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here we go.
So much to go through your mom's house.
I'm your host and dear leader,
Tom Segura,
and she is the fart mistress.
Christina P,
right?
Is that how you want it to be?
Yeah.
The,
yeah,
the Fart.
mistress.com.
We restart.
We still have that one.
We still have it.
I'm trying to get my mom to do it.
Yeah.
What happened with that?
We'll get into it.
I feel like the holidays came.
We got a little baby jeans got off of her more money I think,
whereas it out right now.
Uh,
no.
That's just for me.
It's not,
we're not going to solicit money.
I'm just off.
What?
What's the dollar amount?
I think I offered her a couple of thousand dollars.
She's like,
I'm not there.
Yeah.
Just fart on camera a few times.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not a prostitute at all.
That's not a first little bit of a prostituted farts to toot.
I that's not,
and I don't feel like that's prostitution.
You wouldn't do those for you to do that for free.
You do the other thing for free too.
Well,
yeah,
I guess so.
But uh,
it's not,
it's not illegal,
you know,
farting for money.
Is that illegal?
It's not illegal.
Right.
But fucking for money is so there you go.
There's a legal distinction to be had.
Interesting point.
You always have a point and you can do it in public and get a fart anywhere.
Dean and Christy parade,
devout Christians and they found it on youtube way of spreading God's word
through swinging.
Yeah.
Is This UK master of accents?
Ah,
no,
I don't think so.
They have such a Florida vibe to them,
nor the,
it sounded,
oh maybe it's just the announcer was I liked that guy's cool pink hair and
they're all into like their training fitness levels.
You can tell they're really in,
you know,
bodybuilding.
Yeah.
And I like this guy's shirt.
It's kind of muted.
It's just like a subtle bright neon green.
What color is his hair?
That's like Fuchsia.
That's cool.
Cause he's like,
what is he 60 something?
That's the time to dye your hair.
A few show when you were a man.
And then the other guy he's got,
he's also,
it hits the gym for sure.
Yeah.
A couple of dads and they're in total dad gear too.
They got the cargo shorts with the functional pockets.
I gotta be honest.
Religious swinging is totally new to me.
I'm,
I didn't know I would,
this is one I wish my parents had gotten it.
If they liked the religious part.
Yeah.
They never did the swinging.
I wonder how they're connecting those dots.
Cause Jen early monogamy is the,
the norm.
Yeah,
you know,
we'll see what happens.
If I was a breeze,
go into a swingers club.
Would you listen to me?
You've got a better chance to listen to them.
They read in the word of God being another swinger.
Still a sin.
It's just how are you using right now?
This is God's plan.
Um,
I didn't know that.
I didn't know she had the streets.
I know we were talking about blonde hair with blue streaks.
Is that what you're hung up on?
Because I'm just saying she does have blonde hair with blue streaks.
Pink.
Yeah.
And he has like purple.
It looks great.
It looks good.
Both bodybuilders.
Oh,
that's the no,
you think you can see that?
Yeah.
Cause I don't know.
I'm a little hung up on her non-binary expression expression.
I'm just saying that the voice doesn't match the Oh,
that's the extra test off.
That's what happens when your body build.
You get a lot of testosterone.
That's what we were telling some of the girls sound like me.
My name is Amanda and I'm a ball hog.
Yeah,
that's what we're talking about at lunch yesterday.
That's what I was trying to remember.
You were looking at pictures of this female bodybuilder and we were,
and I was like,
would you ever,
what would you do if I took up bodybuilding?
It would be a lot to you.
It's not the physicality of it.
I mean there's some beautiful female bodybuilders.
They,
some people really like the extremes of the super muscular at,
that's a little much for me,
but I'm saying there's some beautiful women doing it.
It's the lifestyle.
If you're a spouse,
if you're not into it,
it's like any other lifestyle choice because there's so dedicated,
like it's your life 24 seven you don't become super yolked and lean like that
unless you're always on top of like weighing your food,
you're doing your three workouts a day or whatever and you know you had like,
I didn't do lats,
I got to get back in there and then you get your cardio and it would just be
such an all,
you either have to be,
the spouse has to be the all in their support coach type,
like where I'm prepping your food for you.
Like I love that.
She does this shit.
I get her chicken and stuff ready every day.
Flavor list,
fried chicken breasts or it has to be the partner who's doing it totally with
you.
Just by the way,
the same.
The same applies to if you were growing weed at the house or something.
It's like I have to either be supportive of you or doing it with you and I were
dieting together like we were both doing.
You were doing Paleo,
right?
Sorry.
Quito.
It was like on the primal diet.
It's similar so we could support each other.
Yeah,
exactly.
We didn't have bad stuff around the house.
Like I wouldn't bring in like I feel like I got,
I got a brown,
he's 24 seven.
Um,
yes it is.
It is quite a dedicated lifestyle choice.
Holy Moly.
How long do you think you would take me to get my body and like bodybuilder?
Female shape.
13 years.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I'm serious.
Especially a female body to strip your body if it's funny.
A lot of women and some men I've heard,
but you usually hear the women say it more,
they're scared to lift a weight because they think they will turn like the
muscular and it's like you don't understand how much you would have to do for
how long to look like that.
It's not going to happen in a few months of you picking up weights.
I used to think that that's why I wouldn't do any kinds of weight weight
training whenever now that I do,
I do polities now.
But yeah,
I was so afraid of looking too muscular as if that could ever happen.
Never happened.
If you were so into it that you were doing it,
you know,
five days a week for years,
like some of those people that,
that get the really,
really,
really yolked super so crazy or years into doing that.
And you,
the injections,
I imagine you kind of have to do some kind of hormone,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they have the clean,
um,
you know,
competitions where,
but they look different cause they look at them,
they're not as bulky,
you know?
Right.
Cause that's so hard.
That really is kind of,
I don't know much about,
obviously bodybuilding or nutrition or,
I mean,
but you're kind of deforming yourself a little,
aren't you?
A little bit.
Yeah.
They have stretch of body dysmorphia.
I mean,
I'll bet some of the was,
some of them have it so bad,
you know,
cause I've see,
I love those documentaries.
I've watched them like Lou Ferrigno or whatever.
They always talk about pumping and they're always like,
oh,
I have such puny quads.
Right.
I have such puny,
my calves are puny.
And you're like,
oh my God.
No,
they're not brow.
Like those are rocks,
you know?
But they,
oh no,
I'm sorry.
I'm thinking of Jersey Shore.
They're always like,
I don't know what you're saying.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's his name?
The dummy.
Well,
that's the thing.
A lot of those gym rats where those juice heads was guerrilla Jews.
They're all upper body guys.
Right.
They have crazy huge biceps and chest.
And then they had these two little flamingo like sticks.
Yeah.
It's so funny you see that all,
I see that all the time at the Gold's gym.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it'd be
these tiny little legs.
Forget the bottom half.
Yeah,
because they're,
they're mirror their beach guys.
Like they're,
they're,
they're just in the mirror looking at the upper body.
And then I think about the,
but the bodybuilders do it all about proportion.
That's serious.
Serious.
They want it to all match up and look now symmetry.
But let's be okay.
Let's be honest.
Um,
aesthetically speaking,
like if I got super jacked,
like instead of those pictures,
like where I had no fat like Tom,
Tom,
I'm gonna do triceps.
Just
my trainer's not here yet.
Can you get some avocado kind of slice and going after?
Sure.
Babe,
you spot me.
I love you.
Oh,
let's do it.
And like sex and stuff.
I mean,
I,
I would be bigger than you for sure.
If you were doing.
Yeah.
I don't know if you'd be bigger,
but you'd be,
you'd have so much more muscle.
Yeah.
And you'd have to have no fat in their face.
No,
they look kind of like skeletor in the face.
Some of them.
There's no cheeks,
cheeks,
no us,
no buts.
I mean you,
I would be fat less.
I would just be like skeletor you know,
but yeah,
but Jack and then,
uh,
and they always tan the Tan is Tim.
Very dark.
Tanning is most of the work is what I've learned.
I did that just,
it just makes you look glowy,
I'm guessing like healthier.
So think it's all about the,
you see the contrast and the muscles more.
Oh,
Don dark than you do on fair skin.
Yeah.
Okay.
But looks that you can see where the muscles are.
You know what I mean?
Like they couldn't contortion with a con the,
yeah,
I think you see it more on dark skin.
We're asked to start doing it.
I'm dedicated.
What?
Why don't you just get involved in the tanning part?
I actually do need a Tan.
I saw Nikki Glaser at the store the other day and she looked amazing and she
goes,
Oh,
I got a spray Tan.
You got to try it.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's it.
Like you,
she looks healthy and I look like I'm dying.
I don't know if I can do it.
Pragmatic.
Yeah.
Depleted you going to display to and too you want to go?
I don't know if I can do a pregnant woman.
I went to him.
I'll do fake chompers Dwight.
Perfect smiles.
It's a great look.
It's a great,
you gotta get on White,
white,
white by the dedication,
the discipline of those peoples.
The bodybuilders cause they are off the charts disciplined.
I mean they wake up at the crack of dawn there in the gym.
They you're eating and eating is like the most improved.
Yeah.
They eat super clean and they also have to eat a lot of them a lot.
I remember I watched a documentary on a and we were watching the same one.
That guy in the UK that was a bodybuilder and he's like,
you have to love eating.
No,
that wasn't a bodybuilder though.
Those were strong men.
Competition.
Those guys.
By the way,
we watched the disaster artist last night.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was funny.
Was good.
James Franco,
I love James Franco.
He would know he molested people.
Did He molest people?
Something,
I forget his to save you allegedly.
Some kind of Hashtag me too going to the and know they did.
They did report something about it,
but I mean,
I dunno.
I don't think he molests.
Let's get back to her.
I really liked her feminine.
And you're saying that their voices like mine a little bit.
Yeah.
Let me see that.
She's quite a looker too.
Let's not forget him.
Please go into a swingers club.
What'd you listen to me?
You've got a better gross.
It's still a sin.
It's just how are you using right now?
This is God's plan
to make me into a man.
There's hormones in there.
We love swimming as a lifestyle.
And then it was like,
you know what?
We can do a lot of good with this.
I'm getting the people that probably never will.
That's Florida.
Visit a church church.
Oh,
they're gonna.
They're to hold church as a fuck.
I don't know,
but that's what he said.
So he's reaching people that he never would have reached without swinging.
It's such a unique approach.
Why are you spending there are so gross.
Like why do they have to be so creepy about it?
You know,
like the girls stroking the other girl's leg and they're like,
oh,
you feel great.
Then they are all about that fucking,
you know.
Yeah,
they're gross.
They're always so grody about it.
You think so?
Yeah.
I've never seen a documentary on swingers that I would actually want to swing
with.
That's true.
I watched that one on Netflix,
I forget what it's called and they focus a lot on this British.
There was,
I think it was all,
maybe it was all in the UK.
They love it.
And there was this one dude,
he looked like a real fucking old school dad.
You had,
you know,
his Khakis and he was like,
we're having swelling and party here tonight.
And um,
you know,
he had his gray mustache and his wife was his second wife,
third wife,
and she was all in that.
She was like,
I think it's great that he feels,
you know,
so liberated and everything and he's basically just like,
I like to fuck man.
You know,
he's the one,
I want to fuck him.
You and I are going to go on a swinging I think eventually.
Yeah.
Once the kid talking about that,
you know,
we have to go to Florida.
That's where they live.
I think you could find a Jackson,
California.
Jacksonville probably has a good population.
We don't have to go to that.
Why don't we just go to Ventura County?
It's not far.
You think that's where the swingers are for sure.
Santa Clarita.
Sure.
Anybody out there ready to swing,
come over and have a couple of drinks.
Oh Gosh,
you have such nice legs.
It's all like bags of guys,
shoulders and then they had to talk about their boundaries and there,
you know?
Yeah.
What are you into?
What you got into?
I was like,
shooting a scene allowed to pet your penis,
touch your penis,
ejaculate on me.
Like all that stuff.
We have to go over the rules and stuff and you've got to figure out to condoms.
We're going to do tests.
You know,
it would do blood work before.
Wow.
So you go like,
here's my blood work.
She was like,
cool,
I'm down.
It seems like a lot of work.
You want to live the lifestyle or not.
I want to live the lifestyle.
I want to help God.
Praise God.
Let's get got into it today.
True to their word.
It's talking about the Bible with their latest swinging partners.
Oh,
like,
well,
you know,
you're supposed to be a Christian,
but you're a swing.
All the swingers are sinners.
What's the best way to talk to the sinners?
The joy and all right.
Oh,
that makes a lot of sense.
These guys are in the gym a lot to a lot.
Oh,
Johnny's fitness center.
Oh yeah.
That's his jam.
Yeah.
What better way to talk about Jesus and to swing this guys,
so just smile.
They're both like,
we're not interested in this Christian bullshit.
He's just looking at him.
He's just like,
I'm gonna fuck your wife,
dude.
Stop it.
She realizes in the Bible,
gray areas,
it says,
I shall not covet thy neighbor's wife,
but what if your neighbor watch you tube?
It's a good point.
Wait a minute.
Where I go and clean my life?
Was
I living?
Hell yeah.
I got that on my knees and I prayed to God.
I'm like,
please help.
I was,
no,
I didn't expect that turn.
I didn't either.
There's a lot of that though,
right?
Um,
the,
the Bible,
after you go clean and fitness,
fitness is like I am clean now.
I've got all this fucking energy.
I've got to do something with it.
Yeah.
So true.
I stopped drinking.
Now I have to play 10 hours of basketball a day,
seven days a week.
So I do,
I've got to find something man.
He had to find her passion.
She's a little,
she's like,
are you going to fucking right now a lot of nail work there too.
She's one of those broads that like every meals different.
I mean that's got to take hours to do right time cause I get my nails done and
I'm like just one color.
Come on dude,
I don't have all fucking day.
You don't understand the Florida lifestyle fair.
That's all.
That's all there they go,
they're pumping.
She happened to have a female friend there and I get in the showers,
you know,
start showering after work and next thing I know they're both in the shower with
me.
You know,
I didn't know what was going on,
but soon the swinging lifestyle,
the cow off their marriage,
they got they,
they showered at work together.
Is that what understand?
No,
he got home from work and he went to shower and she had a female friend over a
female.
Why can't he say your girlfriend was over?
I don't know.
It's weird when people specify like that.
It's like prisoners,
they talk like that.
She got it was a female and a male.
Yeah,
it's weird.
It's weird to make that distinction like,
Hey,
I'm strictly girl,
boy.
You know,
speaking of prisoners can't get enough of that show,
but it is starting to be more and more upsetting though because I find myself
getting angry every time I watch certain people on that show.
My favorite is the woman who was bringing home the convicted felon of 18 years
with the robbery,
with a deadly weapon.
Assault.
Robbery.
Yeah.
And she's got three,
three children at home and she's like,
instant Daddy,
here's your new dad.
Why don't you like him?
I'm like,
you really need psychological help.
God Damn,
she's really messed up.
And our kids are smarter than she is.
The kids are like far smarter.
He's a convicted felon.
We don't know him and we don't want him to be our instant dad.
And she's like,
you don't want to,
you know,
excited to see them.
And they're like,
no,
no.
She's like,
he's excited to meet you guys.
And they're like,
that's great.
I'm not excited to meet him.
He's a new dad.
What is it?
Love lockup.
So good.
Well I remember my mother met my step dad through a singles ad in the back of
the Indian newspaper.
Yeah.
She liked Indian guys.
So she put an ad out buxom European woman seeks a wealthy Indian husband.
They know.
And we got a bag of,
of letters of course.
Cause Buxom Blonde European woman is like the lead.
So out of all the photographs she chooses him cause he's wearing an Armani suit
next to his Mercedes on a cell phone back in the nineties and I to God,
they got married one month later.
Brick phone.
Yeah.
And they were drug dealer.
He fucking total drug to a hundred thousand percent yeah.
So there could talk on the phone,
Bro.
Yeah,
and I would talk to him on the phone occasionally.
Like,
Oh hey,
I have three daughters.
One of them is into goth music too.
And I was like,
great.
And a month later we were at the courthouse in downtown La.
Same thing like this is your meet your new daddy.
But I actually liked him,
so thank goodness you know anything to get away from my mom.
Anything to take the photos.
So this guy's getting out of prison or no other way it works or why it works or
why worship.
Was it like bank fraud or insider trading?
It was robbery with a deadly,
it's a very violent violet crown.
I want him to be the new man in your life.
That is an interesting thing.
When it's your role model,
you're dead.
You really a thinker.
You have good ideas,
good maternal instinct to protect your kids to like where's the maternal
instinct to protect.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm watching this like you want that man around your children.
He's going to teach them how to make toilet wine.
Baby was fine.
And she's like,
why aren't you guys excited?
You know what I'm saying?
Here's how you lift weights.
He said,
you bench press using nothing but your own body's resistance.
He's a,
he's like,
oh my God,
guys fucked up.
They're all fucked up.
Of course.
Who's dating a fucking felon dude,
you're crazy.
That's not good.
Yeah.
It's funny though.
It's fun to watch.
Fun to get mad.
I know.
Yeah,
you do.
And then I get mad.
I get mad more at the civilians,
not at the prisoners.
The prisoners are actually trying to get their lives.
They're actually trying to meet the parole,
uh,
needs and get jobs.
They're actually all doing what they're supposed to be doing.
And the,
the civilians are like,
why aren't we married yet?
Remember crazy God,
he does every interview.
He's like,
he's like,
ah,
um,
I or we're going to have a great time together.
Yeah.
And people who don't like it then they can get out of my life.
I don't give a shit they want.
And she's like,
they're always like,
I don't know why she doesn't want to have a baby already.
I think she's only been out of prison for two weeks.
Maybe she needs to adjust.
She's clearly using again,
clearly on heroin when her eyes are like,
after she's like,
what's your problem?
Yeah.
Because it never occurred to me that she might be using their,
well,
from what I understand,
prisons not the place to get clean.
Yeah.
Kind of.
It's not a resort.
It's not like a Malibu Rehab,
you know?
No,
I'd be wanting drugs 24,
seven worse.
That's when you started doing drugs or let's get back to swinging.
Yeah.
The Bible doesn't talk about sleep,
uh,
specifically as a married couple.
You agree on something together.
It's okay,
but it's not.
Then like I said,
Judgment Day,
I'll find that out.
Oh,
okay.
You're well,
she's,
she's like,
well,
it's not in the Bible.
It doesn't say you can't swing.
And Jesus' times,
I'm not sure people were,
were they swinging back and I'm sure they were,
but now they've sets up a website.
Oh yeah.
It is for people fucking nails,
man x wingers event and get 10 people that believe in Christ.
Uh,
looking at her,
looking down like I don't know about.
She's like,
I'm into the swinging part of it man.
He's like,
he's trying to find the hole,
the loophole that it's really about spreading the Gospel.
Jesus,
she's like,
she's real shiny.
He has good intentions but he's delusional.
Yeah,
just be swingers recruits it help running the site from close to home.
My mom on a six website.
Whoa.
I am not currently involved in lifestyle.
It's never a non possibility.
Wa that's her daughter by the way.
Who's doing how?
Peng fitness swingers site.
Whether it's not,
not a,
not a not possibility that she becomes and bald.
The swinging is that one good parenting.
Good religion.
Good,
good,
good.
All good.
A lot of bright colors.
These few people got bright colors and the poor daughter.
Yeah,
she's,
I enter the lifestyle.
She's I at know either lifestyle,
the lifestyle lifestyle.
So far today God hasn't said,
hey dean stopped us.
It's a sin.
I don't want you to do this.
What are you expecting of till we close that?
I'm going to keep trying to help as many people as we can.
That's what I don't
like the spin.
Yeah.
This is all about help.
It's all about busted a nut,
which I'm not mad at.
I'm mad at you,
but don't,
don't make God the pimp.
You know,
he should play this for your parents and see if they agree with Catholicism,
Dad,
and know you're going to retire soon.
Have you thought about expanding and
maybe bringing,
spreading God the message of the Lord in a different way?
You know,
uh,
unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
Um,
oh,
can I,
can we pull out the article I sent you?
Oh yeah.
So I got the sense to me from my friend Eric.
Apparently there's a man who's chosen to live as a Dalmatian.
A 32 year old man has taken it,
has decided to live as a domesticated Dalmatian.
Uh Oh,
Tom Peters told U K is this morning while he uses his real name,
when he works at his job as a lighting and theater technician.
He likes to be referred to as spot.
When he transforms into a puppy.
Peter said is Dalmatian costume helps them transform into his persona of a
puppy,
which is a lifestyle he is fully committed to.
He sleep.
He sleeps in an enclosure,
walks on all fours and eats from a dog bowl.
Will you scroll down a bit further?
Yeah.
Here's my favorite part,
which you guys are all going to appreciate.
Yeah.
On,
hold on.
Uh,
okay.
Peter added that contrary to popular belief,
people who chose,
chose to live their lives as dogs aren't doing it to cause mischief or sexual
pleasure,
but rather to have fun and literally be treated like a puppy.
It is not a sexual thing.
It's a lifestyle.
It's just escapism to get away from fund a n,
d and the frenetic life.
We have
said,
fine.
You started locking I guess money.
It's not sexual guys.
Oh,
sure.
look at you.
My is like that.
No,
please.
You don't have a title.
Oh No,
no.
I don't like this puppy.
Yeah.
Push down on that if you think it's been so.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
not sexual.
Tom,
what's,
what was sexual about that in the least?
Yeah,
you've come because you need to tail revenue shared hoppy.
Yeah.
It's just the tower you'd lock us.
We'll give you
and then cause your last choice.
Okay.
So this is this.
Oh,
scroll up and see if we owe on the loan side advertising and as you're being
heard.
Ah,
well the,
the,
the lead photo,
she doesn't look too happy.
If you look at the photograph of two of them.
No,
she doesn't look happy.
Uh,
I,
it doesn't say where they live,
if that's you.
That's what I'm saying.
Like,
okay,
what'd you hate?
So I'm like,
Babe,
we're Dalmatian 24,
seven.
I want to,
when I'm home I want to be a dog and I have to create you at night and stuff.
And you got to tell our son like a dad.
He's a dog.
Oh,
oh,
oh so nasty with sexual about this dog.
And that's sexual is a lifestyle dog.
Right?
Uh,
can't have fun.
Okay.
Would you rather,
and I'm like having a good time.
Would you rather become a bodybuilder like full year in it?
You really got to dedicate for a decade or live as a Dalmatian for a decade.
Yeah,
they're both for a decade.
Yeah.
We'll see how long it takes to become a dedicated bodybuilder.
Well,
first of all,
I mean it's,
it's gotta be bodybuilder.
I'm not excited about it.
I don't want to do it,
but there's no way I could throw myself into the copy lifestyle for a decade.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
look,
I mean,
I would never work again if I was a puppy.
You might like it boarding flights and I'd be like,
you have to sit under the seat.
I'm my own emotional.
Cool.
What is it in emotional needs,
dog?
No,
Dean's door I'd bring you on is my emotional needs.
Puppy.
You can sit on my lap.
Okay.
Very tight down there on Chicago.
Very tired.
But you could sleep with Fifo and Betsy and I could feed the three of you at the
same time.
We really easy.
It'd be great.
Oh,
how do presets wrapping up the kid at school?
That'd be so pissed about bodybuilding.
That's the one thing I definitely don't want to do.
I'm going to come on.
I know.
It's so hard.
It's just too hard.
It's,
I don't want to do it hard.
You don't want it.
Don't want to do it.
Oh,
hold on.
Hold on.
Papi,
he's going to k
nothing as gross as it.
Nothing in the world can be as gross as a man can be.
There's never women doing this.
It's never like never cute.
Girls being like,
I want to be a dog.
I want you to put a tale in my,
but no,
it's no worries guys.
Yeah.
Why are guys so discussed as being like,
I'm want to be a dog.
Make sure we're at and we pretend we're at the vet and I need a tail,
but really you just shoved this dildo up my ass hole and it,
we'll call it a tale.
Why are they such savages?
Tom?
What's going on with you guys?
We're just fucked up,
man.
I don't know why this is just like a misdirected sexual energy,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe it's,
it's a frustrated sexual energy because you don't have,
you don't have immediate access to women or men or whatever.
Man,
I think it has a lot to do with,
you know,
at some point this guy wanted to express some sexual thing,
some kink and you oppressed and repressed it and then you keep her pressing it
and then maybe he teases it once to someone and he gets shot down.
So then it goes back to being bottled up,
bottled up.
And then one day he's like,
I'm going to live life as a dog.
And then you guys just fucking put me in a cage.
And it goes to an extreme.
Yeah.
Cause it's also,
there's nothing wrong.
I'm not trying to kink shame people,
but
to live your life as a dog is an extreme.
Obviously that's not like,
yeah,
24 seven is a bit much.
I mean I understand,
I understand the,
you know,
recreational maybe on the weekends or wherever the heck yeah.
Maybe women too in society haven't really been as encouraged to explore there.
That's true.
So maybe in another generation or two and there is a lot of kink shaming on
probably either side you mean?
Yeah.
Well women don't even admit to,
yeah.
You know,
simple thing guys,
when they're young are told basically don't be weird.
Yeah.
Well everyone's told.
Oh right.
Yeah,
I think so,
but I'm saying so you need to like healthy encouragement.
Yeah.
Of Your Shit.
Things like this.
Cool.
Oh,
good puppy spin around.
Spin around.
Let's you from the front.
I'm an af copy.
Yeah.
You put a tail.
No,
please.
I don't want the tail towed away.
I think about my sweet little dog.
No,
I'm a dog lover.
Anyways,
new topic.
You and I have been having social dinners very early lately.
That's um,
part of our new lifestyle.
Some people are in the spending and Jesus and we're into going to bed.
So I'm into it.
I'm into it to you.
You fucking,
I was a late night guy for so long.
You know,
our whole relationship.
It was all what you've been going to bed.
And I'd be like,
I'll see you when I see you,
man.
I would be up till two,
three in the morning and the raccoons.
Ooh.
Wow.
That out then,
whatever.
And that was just life in this human boy came into our house has just changed.
But I miss,
I miss having sleep.
So yeah,
you got to,
you got to kind of move to his schedule.
I need to be home early.
I don't like this late night.
I don't eat or it doesn't work for us anymore.
So we had dinner with some business friends and as a joke I throughout 6:00 PM I
was like there's no way he's gonna even five 30 I think I threw out there,
I was like five 36 and you typed it into the group texts,
you're like yeah,
six o'clock I was like babe,
I'm kidding.
Nobody eats dinner at six except us privately.
Like we'll go down to the steak house in the neighborhood and eat at six
o'clock.
We do.
Yeah.
But the guy agreed he did and he and his wife,
they have the three children right to add to along the way.
And they loved it too.
They were like,
great,
this is great.
Well I love it when you get home in time to watch your show kind of mellow out.
Cause if you go to the eight o'clock dinner,
forget it when you're home at 10 30 or it's late now I go right to sleep.
I can't watch my love after lock up.
That's right.
Can't have it.
But you know the tree treat little snack.
Now this is just perfect Tommy.
And it's good because the restaurant's still empty.
Yeah,
you're there right before the dinner rush.
I don't mind it.
I don't mind it either.
It's a little embarrassing.
It makes getting up tolerable too because you know,
I've had to adapt and now I get up every day around seven yes.
You know,
I,
cause I made plans with my mom friends and these are the two girls I,
I grew up with,
went to school with and they were my sluttiest drinkingest friends.
Right.
So these two slots,
they're like,
Yay,
let's have dinner at nine and a,
and I was like,
Yo,
I mean can we get that down to eight and then I'll be in the car,
I'll be coming ubering home at 10 you know what I'm saying?
That these two slots,
they stay out till one,
two in the morning.
I'm like,
yeah,
but you got to wake up with your baby.
They had,
you know,
one and a half year olds at the time.
Oh,
you guys are fucking nuts.
Hung over it.
They just,
they punish themselves and they take care of the baby over,
which I can't.
I just can't.
I just can't do it
physically capable.
I don't want to,
I don't.
Why can't I get drunk at 7:00 PM I can still get drunk.
Let's just move it up.
It started six bro,
and then I'm in bed by 10 I don't have to start at 10 and your fucking mind if,
if we're doing a road thing,
do a late out night and then have to get up early to like,
oh,
fuck that bro.
I can't do that shit.
No,
no,
no.
I either have to move my flight or just not do this.
Yeah,
no,
you got to go to sleep.
Sleep,
sleep,
number one.
Number one is at the top of the list of things I need.
Yup.
Put me in a good mood.
I can't function.
No,
I dunno.
There's these people that do the three or four hours.
They not these folks I would they say is like that.
Some celebrities that they said,
oh,
I heard the Chappelle is like that.
Right.
I was at the escalation like that.
Chris Rock and Chappelle were there and they were doing the same show in the
belly room,
the little ADC room,
and I was talking to one of the guys that traveled with him a lot.
He's like,
yeah,
you know,
he's looking at a Taurus late night guy and I go also.
Then he just goes to,
you know,
he's like,
we do a lot of 6:00 AM 7:00 AM stay up til six or 7:00 AM should me.
No Way.
And then I go,
but then like you guys sleep all that.
He's like,
no,
that's the crazy part is that he'll be up at like nine or 10 he just needs a few
hours.
I mean,
I envy these people.
I've always wished I wear that type that didn't need to sleep.
I slept three or four,
I'm fine,
I'm great.
And then go play sports.
The next day I,
it's just not my constitution.
Life exhausts me so much.
Like I just got exhausted.
I'm sick right now and I'm,
my theory is still that it,
that it happened when I got bad sleep.
I went to bed real late the other night and I had to get up and I could feel
myself breaking down.
I don't know how he's going to do it if I don't rest enough and forgetting to
get second smokers smoking's no good.
I know,
but he's still is like just going fine.
I know some people are genetically freak so,
um,
my father had a friend,
the guy is dead now so I can talk about it.
I'm hoping it was just wired that way too.
Like this dude with slave,
like he would party,
right?
Like the card,
like you name it.
That guy was doing it and sleep three or four hours.
No wait guy.
I can do,
I like being up late but I have to be able to sleep of course.
But then he'd wake up,
go play soccer because he leaves a Hungarian guy and he loved to play soccer.
Fucking a and then all day like do whatever.
Like you're crazy.
You remember when I used to work the graveyard shift so that was very bad for
you.
It was really bad.
And so I was up very bad shift would end around like 6:00 AM I think.
Ooh that's 7:00 AM that's tough.
One I would go home and you know you hit like weird second wins and I would have
to do something to kind of wind down and then I would go to bed and I mean I
would sleep
sometimes an hour before I had to go back to work.
Go.
Yeah.
And I was telling one of the guys I worked with and he was like why do you sleep
so much?
What?
He's like,
yeah just cause he was also in the graveyard and he was like yeah I just said a
few hours and then I'm like,
oh wish I,
I'm falling apart.
That was falling apart and that would go in the edit bays cause it was an a post
production place and I would fall asleep on one of the Anti Edit Bay couches.
And this guy one time an editor junior at a assistant editor came in,
it was like,
man you're,
you're snoring.
We can hear it down though.
Of course.
I was like,
cause it was three 30 or four in the morning and I was just know.
Well plus it messes up your metabolism.
Everything you eat when you're not eating it,
you shouldn't be eating it three or four in the morning.
It slows everything down.
That's when I first started to put on weight.
Yeah,
he was doing that.
That shift actually.
Yeah,
of course.
I went into that thing around 200 pounds,
you know,
like one 95 200 pounds when I,
when I started working in those jobs and like after six months of doing crazy
shifts and then graveyard shift that was 25 pounds heavier.
No,
yeah,
sure.
I was gaining weight,
just working the clubs.
When we remember we were talking about,
Oh,
here's where you and I were on the road,
grinding away,
grinding out weeks.
We would,
this is our,
our schedule back in 2010 was it Tom and I would do this show.
Can we,
we tape your mom's house on Tuesdays.
We both get on planes Wednesdays to go do the clubs.
Yeah.
Do shows Wednesday through Sunday.
What they would do is they would have thought,
they would say you have to leave Wednesday to do Thursday morning press press.
Right.
The whole thing's about,
and that's like good morning.
Hard for,
I'm like some,
you know,
some bullshit radio.
None of which ever paid off.
That's why you had to leave on Wednesday to do the Fockers shit.
Fucking local press that nobody who likes what we do ever listens to or watches.
No.
Okay,
so then Thursday you're so Wednesday you fly across the country.
Yeah.
Two planes.
Usually we were picking you up at 6:00 AM eastern time.
We're west coast body clock,
so it's three again for us.
Wake up,
take you to these fucking dumps.
Yeah.
Where the guy doesn't care.
Didn't look up well you,
what do you do?
I'll just say I'm Tom's here and just take it from there.
Yeah.
What?
Like they wouldn't know.
It wouldn't look up anything about you.
And then you do that press for like three hours.
Then you're like holy shit.
Then you eat breakfast,
then you go to sleep and you would sleep like four or five hours or something.
Then a show Thursday,
sometimes it would have Friday press too.
Right.
They wake you up the next day to do press again.
Two shows Friday two show,
Saturday one show Sunday.
Yes.
All that fly back home Monday.
Sometimes on a connecting flight.
Yeah.
So now you're back in la ideally by two,
two or 3:00 PM if you're lucky.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
We get home.
We'd get the dog.
Cause at the time we just had FIFO with this,
this nice man that would watch fief and he'd bring them over.
Uh,
we'd make dinner,
we'd regroup next morning,
wake up,
do your mom's house,
do whatever.
You fucking me.
You know,
things you had to do,
anything we're luck,
unpacked,
do your laundry and everything.
It was terrible.
Lucky,
so hard.
Like I'm staying on the stay at home as we did making those,
fuck,
I'm going out again.
Yeah.
I mean,
but we were,
we were just talking about it that those years when you and I were just like
grinding,
like you kind of,
we had to do that to get here obviously,
but of course,
but those were the years,
man.
If just I would,
I remember when we lived in Redondo,
I would land at the airport and how it just put my bags down because we lived on
less than a mile from the beach.
We rented like this little house and we'll go south.
Yeah.
And I will go to the beach and I was just fucking lay on the sand and the field
is sunlight after being in these dark places,
you know,
cause you're nocturnal when you're a comic too.
It's not like you,
I didn't go out during the day,
so I would just be in a dark hotel room to go to the club.
Eating,
crying,
drinking.
Good Lord.
Thank God those days are over with terrible man making your money.
My name is Alexa and I'm a bell.
Huh?
You can get her to say stuff like that.
I mean somebody's got a,
who did this?
What a slut.
Kelly Kelly from Brooklyn and I had it done.
Good job gains.
Is Alexa [inaudible]?
Yeah,
I'm a ball hog.
I got a great a great one.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Hi,
I'm Payton Lafferty and Bajans
this guy,
I don't know what city this is in.
Um,
this is in Florida,
I think Peyton blast.
Um,
you said he's driving home and he hears this guy on the radio named Jim Fisher,
one of these,
I don't know,
talk radio guys.
And he's rambling on about how transgender people are taking a drug to lactate,
right.
Oh,
okay.
Cause they want to be able to breastfeed to sure.
So he called in to the show.
Okay.
Um,
he says he did call him pancake the IBS champ.
But this is really great.
So he had his,
it's not the most premium audio,
but because he told his friends to record it for them.
So he's like,
there's a couple,
you know,
it's not like super clear.
It's not from the station,
but this is the best.
Uh,
this is just,
this is great.
This is him calling into this Guy Jim fresh.
Your show.
Here we go.
Okay.
Hi Jan.
Longtime time listener.
I'm pleading Lafferty and I'm a ball hog.
Yeah,
I was born Jamie Laverty.
I'd be going to three ambitions through years ago.
Outline giving you an idea of how we feel in the transgender community about
this
man.
I just talked about it and we thank,
you know,
moms are eating so many GMOs are eating too and things are parasite.
That's not how I want to exceed the genic diet.
No,
I would have married come an oil paint.
That's not true.
Yes it is.
No paper.
That's not true.
Have you been around a nursing mother anytime in your life?
Yeah,
and she was eating Gmos and junk food and all this stuff.
She wasn't careful about what she ate.
Right.
And lose silk and every hallway,
loosen everything,
Soup and everything.
Lariat.
God just keeps going.
I'm going to raise my children the way I want to and I'm going to raise them
with non gender pronoun.
You used to be,
I gather a guy.
Uh,
yeah.
Okay.
You're not going to have any children.
I am.
I'm going to endow.
Okay.
Have you had your plumbing ripped out to know that's why they call me a ball
hog.
Your plumbing ripped out.
I mean how,
how rude can,
can't be your plumbing ramps.
I like how disrespectful.
Don't be it.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's totally a dick.
I mean,
I'm a Douche bag and he's,
he's also has that holier than now.
Yeah.
Tones.
Very condescending tone.
Yeah.
Fuck.
I'm going to raise my kids the way I want her.
It was my paper.
I'm going to call them when they're born.
Just like in Sweden,
they call all kids hand.
It's a non gender specific shone out.
Once they get to an age where they realize they want to be a Sam or is there or
hear or see them,
they get and make that place.
He's really good at this by,
he's really good at it.
Yeah.
Wow.
Peyton,
you did a really good job.
Gosh.
Yeah.
I mean I would have laughed the whole time.
He didn't laugh at all.
He didn't really good.
He stuck to it.
I think he actually got into character.
I think he was just feels like when you're acting and you really,
when the,
when the choice you make really lines up for you and the Improv is natural.
You don't have to search for it.
It really feels like he became the ball.
Hockey became a ball hog on that.
So good.
I liked that.
He was okay.
I want to Quito genic diet.
I like that he's on a ketone or she,
excuse me,
page.
Hey.
Yeah.
They didn't specify their pronouns.
Talking.
Yeah.
It was really great.
Good job.
Amaze.
That was,
that was really good.
You know,
you guys in their moves,
soup and everything,
that guy sounds like such an asshole.
What a dickhead and you know,
they don't rip out.
Get your plumbing ripped out yet.
And actually he's not right.
Cause all my friends were drinking and stuff and I know where the fuck they want
and he thinks he speaks for all women are breastfeeding.
Yeah,
but he knows Lee's.
What is this?
You put this in here.
While we're getting asked by my boyfriend,
sweetheart,
I don't want you to be alarmed.
Okay?
I know this may come as a shock to you,
but I do have your best interests at heart.
Why did you put that in there?
Well,
I don't know.
Three pouring club.
She knew.
That's your job.
Now I need to make sure the doctor knows how to use his penis properly before he
can fill your perfect little holes.
Oh my interest,
my interest dying new quick,
but fucking my mother so I can talk to her.
Well,
this is crazy,
man.
Yeah,
that's a genre,
Huh?
No,
this is a genre.
How do they label that one?
I don't know.
Mom gets me,
my mother,
so I can talk to her.
Well,
let me guess.
A little bit of incest.
Incest,
anal,
but isn't the answer.
It's the Jason because he's just,
she's not like involved.
She's just like,
dude,
stop fucking my mom.
Oh,
so we don't know if that's her son.
I'm inferring that.
No,
no,
no.
The her son.
It's,
it's the daughter's boyfriend I think.
Right.
So it's uh,
gosh,
I mean that's,
it's mill is getting the boyfriend ready for her daughter.
Oh,
okay.
I see.
Okay.
Just like the daughter has a boyfriend.
Oh yeah.
And the mom's like,
I don't know if you know what you're doing yet.
Okay.
I'm going to teach you mom.
You can please my daughter.
I'm trying to think of what the,
the,
the clip title is though.
Mom getting asked that to by my boyfriend.
Maybe mom teaches daughter's boyfriend.
How to give her daughter good anal,
something like that.
That the class too long.
It's too long.
But yeah,
you're on the right.
I should have been a writer for all these porn.
You would have a Donny guide,
new quit,
but be my mother so I can talk to her.
But fucking yeah,
but fucking is a good word.
I like about a couple of words together.
Yeah,
but fucking are you guys but fucking or whatever.
but fucking,
it's good to see something kind of gross.
Yeah.
Uh,
this lady is taking a dump in public.
There's names later day.
Why are you going to do it right here though?
Why you ain't got to a cone ozone?
Why don't you take your pick j don't,
oh well get my life,
Huh?
Yeah.
You see it like that.
Don't let the day.
No,
you piss wait a tissue.
It.
Ooh.
I hope I ain't stepping on you.
Right.
I'm about to tell him I be saying
ugly.
Be Dead.
Did you know in India they're trying to pass a law that you can't poop in public
anymore?
Is it a big problem there?
Yes.
Really overpopulated.
People Shit and piss everywhere.
Some people are upset because they want to be one of those people to shit in the
street.
Oh No.
I'd be one of the people.
They'd be like,
can everyone stop doing this please?
It's really bothering me.
Yeah,
me too.
Yeah.
But some people are upset because they don't want their right to shit in public.
Taken away.
Well,
I get it.
I mean,
there's probably is not enough toilets.
No,
there's more than a billion people there.
So many people.
But anything that's the problem.
There's not enough toilets.
I don't know.
Well,
kind of access to toilets.
Yeah.
Perhaps.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of people did a lot of it.
I mean,
of course the real problem is just the most horrific poverty.
You can imagine that too.
Yeah.
It's a problem.
Well,
okay.
Uh,
would you rather live in India for one year?
Okay.
Or live as a Dalmatian amongst our dogs for one year ago.
Now when you live in India,
by the way,
here's the thing.
You're not,
you're,
you're living in like the level that most Indians live in.
Like the majority,
I'm assuming that's not very good.
I mean,
what level is that in the,
you're not the 1% put it that way.
You're working class.
You pull a fucking wreck Shah or what's not working class?
What's that?
That's lower class.
Okay,
so,
so you're,
you're,
you're pulling a,
you're driving that took,
took her wherever.
Fuck.
What do they have there in India?
God,
could this be any more disrespectful?
What did they do?
What do you mean?
What are they doing?
The fucking,
the cabs.
What are they called?
Their cabs?
Nah,
they're not called calves.
I don't know.
You know what I'm saying?
You,
you pull a rickshaw essentially.
Here.
Let's look it up.
I saw it in that movie.
The marigold hotel at the took tuck is what they are.
I don't know.
Hey,
you're that guy or you're a fucking Dalmatian.
Look,
here's what I looked up.
Tuck,
tuck.
I looked up taxis in India.
Regular fucking,
but that's not what I want you to do.
I want you to the one that you pedal,
that's a different story.
How do you,
right,
let me see.
Paddlers.
Right pedal.
Yeah.
PDA,
right.
Pedal,
pedal,
pedal.
Or is it p e t a.
L something like,
yeah,
I want you to,
okay.
Yeah.
Like one of those things like a cart and you pull the,
you pull the person in the cart.
All right.
Or you're a Dalmatian and our house huddler an India
hundred percent.
Not even a doubt in my mind.
It'd be great to do that type of work.
It'd be humbling.
I would um,
make new friends
finally stopped doing comedy.
Yeah.
Alison took,
took,
which is known as Auto Rick Shot in India.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
Tuck Tux.
So you got to buy her tuck talk.
How much does it cost?
I'm looking it up right now.
Oh,
it's all right.
It's a lot.
It's about $2,900 to buy one of those took Tux.
But I'll give you that money or start your business.
Yeah.
There you go.
You got to drive that fucking thing around.
I'll do that one year.
One year in India.
But you've,
you've seen how they drive in India.
It's crazy.
It's really dangerous dude.
And they just run over people.
They don't give a shit dead bodies everywhere.
Everywhere and everywhere.
He had to stop for the cows.
I would do it.
Stupid tourists and stuff.
I'm into it.
You have to live in that class.
Do you think this is true?
This is real right here.
What would you do by the way?
Don't make you lose a fucking Dalmatian.
Dude,
he is terrible.
My stepdad would talk about how horrible it was all the time.
Come on.
You would live in like a tiny box.
First of all,
you would live in squalor.
You sound so naive.
No,
I'm telling him.
My stepdad used to fucking tell me why do you think he left that country?
Do you and he didn't like it?
I think it'd be all right.
Let me come on.
People go there all the time.
We get diarrhea like that.
That's another thing.
I get diarrhea every day.
That's true.
You don't like Indian food?
I love Indian food.
You've never even with me once in the time we've been together,
you are.
Your memory is really of concern.
I want you to know,
I want you to go see a neurologist.
I'm serious.
I really rarely have mom brain.
You know this?
No,
no,
no.
Over that excuse.
When's the last time we ended?
Somebody by the way messaged me that remember I was at,
we're playing that clip and I go on the last episode come.
Yes.
And they're like,
dude,
you guys played it five months ago and Christina was like,
wow,
no,
we've definitely never played that.
I'm just,
I'm going out of their concerns.
Wait,
wait.
Okay.
But wait,
seriously,
when's the last time we had,
I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you together.
I don't know,
but I do know that I have multiple memories of suggesting Indian Food and you
shutting it down and being like,
we're going to get diarrhea.
We are going to get diarrhea.
You,
especially when we lived on the east side,
every time I would suggest Indian food,
you would always be like,
we're going to get sick,
read diary.
I don't want to do that.
And you had bad memories of going to one and there was a rat at one or
something.
Yeah,
well my Stepdad used to drag us all these fucking dirty Indian places growing up
I just didn't like,
cause I,
I,
I had enough.
You know what I mean?
I'm not,
I'm going to have smell like fucking staff are.
I'm just saying I liked their food 14 years.
Okay.
At was already in today.
I'm in.
I like that Tandoori chicken I'm in.
I'm totally a no,
cause I worked at the electric Lotus in most fields.
I worked at an Indian restaurant and that shit was nasty as hell.
Okay,
so see,
I wasn't in that off.
You didn't like it do to keep the mango Chutney and like,
uh,
just a been filthy band.
Everyone put their fucking hands in it.
In their defense.
A lot of different genres of food have shitty restaurants.
They all do.
Everybody.
No Americans discussed.
Why don't we,
why don't we look up a good Indian food area?
I like to do that and I,
yeah,
no,
no.
Do Rob,
Rob,
rob,
do you think this is real
funny,
funny?
How
come?
Nothing.
What do you mean nothing?
I found something now
that's not real.
It's bad acting,
right?
Yeah.
That's,
I sent that in.
We played this already.
No,
we played it without playing it on the show.
Played it two weeks.
How's our memories work?
Oh my God.
Someone was that the memory champion.
Look,
you will.
You would concede that point man.
Not The memory champion.
You want to know why I'm growing a human life inside of me.
That takes up a lot of my resources be I take care of it.
Fucking two year olds.
I'm responsible for a lot of his life as you are as well.
Two dogs,
a husband myself.
It's a lot.
A lot plates to juggle career Pi Casting,
Netflix watching.
I don't have a real estate in here anymore.
Can you read that email?
Miss gendered cat.
Ms gendering cat.
Hey dog cons.
Just recently a friend of mine got a kitten from a coworker and it was informed
by her that it was female.
Apparently she's retarded because upon further inspection it was discovered that
the kitten is actually a male.
You Mommy's know as well as I do that biological sex is a myth and gender is a
spectrum,
so this is okay.
Despite the fact that the Zimmers or feeling in question is called smokey,
which is gender neutral.
We still have a problem because we were under the impression this kitten is
female.
We had been mis-gendering at the whole time.
Have we unknowingly created permanent trauma in zooms short life?
Is there a chance to,
can actually identifies as female,
therefore making us correct.
Are we driving the kid to suicide with our Trans Phobia?
The consequences of our bigotry are endless.
Even worse,
there is the possibility that the kit and identifies with its male biology,
which would make it a privilege,
cisgendered male piece of shit that we would probably have to bring to the vet
to be put down.
Anyway,
I've got to go get fucked by a couple of hot black guys who just got out of
prison.
Thanks for all you do mommies and congratulation on baby jeans.
Two Point Oh which I hope you give a nonbinary name.
Beat me,
piss on me.
Tried out Adam from Maine.
Wow.
What,
what a [inaudible] very well written email it
and I think um,
I think you guys really did make a huge mistake.
Everyone involved at this point?
I would say I would let that cat just into the wilderness.
Well,
is the cast so traumatized worth,
I mean there's a certain point like you can't help someone,
you can't help something.
I mean,
as a therapist you could take the cat to,
there are animal therapists and professional cuddlers and those that can speak
to animals on the level that most of us can't.
Um,
what does it,
what does the animal to called a psychic?
I can animal sidekick and they could probably communicate with this.
I'm sure if they do communicate,
they're going to say things like,
I didn't think it was funny and I want wanna I want to move,
I want to get the hell out of Maine and get over to the Vermont where it's more
my speed.
Wow.
More my type and smokey,
isn't that a racial slur as well?
So not only have we,
uh,
mis-gendered this poor cat,
we've also given it a racist name.
So hello.
Racial problems and gender problems.
So this is,
um,
this is a very problematic cal.
I think,
you know what I would do maybe at this point,
first of all is I would 100% um,
I would assume that the cat liked being
addressed as a female and I would go back to treating it like a female high,
but its genitalia is male.
Yeah.
Because it was obviously the cat knew that it wanted to be a female and that's
why the original owner was like,
it's a female that that owner probably know something about that cat.
So by you treating it as a male,
you're being super disrespectful.
It probably to the cats wishes.
Sure.
I Dunno.
I mean the good news is is that Smokey's kind of a gender neutral name,
so they may have salvaged it's gender crisis shut her identity crisis.
Well,
and by the way,
cats don't share the same gender orientations that humans do.
There's a whole different spectrum,
I'm sure if cat gender,
so aren't there.
I think the,
what's obvious is that all though this cat has male genitalia,
it's a female at heart.
So I think you should,
you should be treating it as such.
Okay.
I think you're assuming it's true.
I think you're assuming it's Pronoun.
The swallowing come make me a cannibal.
Hmm hmm.
As they come kind of sore.
I woke up this morning smelling like dicks and I was wondering is there a
millions of potential of humans in sperm when you swallow all that come,
does that make you a cannibal?
Hmm.
Uh,
certainly messes my chances of being Vegan.
I'm sure asking Mommy's gives me the best chance of getting a well analyzed
answer to my question.
In Jesus's name,
Lisa,
the ball hog.
Wow.
Lisa.
It like a yo angel.
Um,
what do you think gene?
Well,
human life doesn't start a sperm,
uh,
without egg.
So I,
you know,
cause all those right to life or folks don't get upset when you just spill Jizz
on fee convict shine.
They get upset when you kill a baby,
a person.
So I don't think it's cannibalism per say.
It's maybe partial cannibalism to eat it.
It's not,
it's not yet a human is what I'm trying to get out.
But it is an a product created from another animal.
You know,
the only,
the only loophole in this,
and when she's not asking us,
she vegan,
she's asking,
is it cannibalism?
Cannibalism implies eating another human.
Right,
right.
Mm.
Yeah.
It's not a human yet.
It's just a spur.
It's part of a human part of a human.
Right.
But I mean,
she's on her way.
Oh No.
Oh,
I want to say no,
I think you're safe.
You can,
you can drink as much as,
as you want.
I'd say don't worry about it.
Wow.
Keep drinking all of that.
Um,
I'm uh,
I'm not,
I'm not on board with Christina on this one for sure,
but seriously.
Yeah,
I don't think so.
Well,
what are you trying to say?
That it is cannibalism?
I think you're pretty much on your way.
I think it's,
um,
I think it's something you'd,
if I,
if I were you,
I would throw in the towel on that and try to try to,
um,
try to make it right with your life right now.
Okay.
I know we do need to think of some non-binary
names for our future son.
You mean son
idiot
for a future.
Sims are,
what are some good non a gender neutral names?
Casey?
Casey's a good one.
Uh,
Pat,
obviously Chris.
Chris goes both ways.
Very neutral.
We have to think of a,
a lot of these diamond.
Yeah.
They've diamonds pretty female?
I don't think so.
I know a lot of cool guys named Diamond Shit.
Speaking of ges and all that,
this is interesting.
We featured this guy a few weeks ago and he has a new,
a bit of information.
He wanted to share it and for him,
no.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the other day when I get a hug from my chick of,
of or afterwards I'm born free came and my pants literally pre came and my pants
a couple of minutes after that.
Boehner and then it went away.
Okay.
So that's why he knows he's straight.
Oh,
okay.
I tend to think if you haven't had sex in a long ass fucking time,
oh,
what the f is some female just gives you a hug and it gives you a boner and then
you pre come your pants afterwards.
I tend to think that you're straight.
I Dunno.
I didn't know that,
that it was that
big of a deal.
I think he's,
it's almost like he's trying to prove that he's straight.
He's probably getting a lot of comments like you,
you look like a fat.
That's what I was going to say.
Yeah.
Well Golf guys get a lot of that stuff.
You're gay.
Yeah.
Usually your home,
all your stupid hair and your stupid black things and your dog collar and he's
proving that he's not by telling you that he almost came in his pants just by
getting a hug from come hug.
Yeah.
This guy,
he's trying to say he invented the combine.
He's saying he's the come hugger.
Yeah.
I do like his theory about inhaling the fart though.
That's the same guy who said that if you,
uh,
if he fars at work,
he tries to snip it off so nobody else can smell it.
And I swear I've had the same exact thought too.
I can't,
I can't lie and say that a habit that you can sniff it all up.
Yeah.
Like if I inhale deeply right now,
maybe I can save it like the other people won't smell it.
I've had the exact same stupid thought.
Well then I go,
oh,
that's stupid.
That's not possible.
Yeah.
I have come all over my face,
nerve Karma,
aunts and dad shoes on.
Oh,
tell me about it.
I'll show you.
You got these for me.
Can you guys say that?
Yeah.
Can you see those?
Yeah,
there's so daddy shoes.
They're like,
they're a d dos,
but they don't,
I mean,
I don't look sexy.
I feel like I look like a total dad boner,
but they're so good.
It's like walking on boats.
Yeah.
They feel really nice and they're slip on,
which I'm a huge fan of their,
their fantastic right now.
Really Nice.
By the way,
I want,
I wanted to mention this before.
Oh yeah.
This is an honor of,
of you really.
I mean,
no boy,
no,
no.
This is good for,
it's never positive on her.
You know,
this is good.
We're going to like it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
this guy,
yeah.
He,
he wrote in,
Christina made me realize current map of the United States is inaccurate.
And so he worked on this and we liked it so much that we decided we're going to
do it.
We're going to
put it in our store.
Oh,
this,
I love this.
Yeah,
you're right.
This is my favorite store now.
It is a map of the United States.
Yeah,
I'm sure it has a,
it says not Los Angeles everywhere.
And then Los Angeles.
We're in Los Angeles.
This looks right to me.
This is how I see America.
I love the shirt though.
It is great.
If you want to rep la
cool shirt.
Uh,
he wrote my c Cups,
let girlfriend,
her brother and I all went to des Moines.
Um,
well we had a great time.
One could say that a [inaudible] or whenever.
It was.
Great meeting you.
Anyways,
piss on me.
Beat me.
Yeah.
Uh,
Caleb Bene set this.
Caleb,
I got to tell you,
this is probably one of my favorites.
I love it.
Absolutely love this shirt.
I can't wait to wear it.
I think it's so fun.
So it's in the store now.
If you want to order one Angelenos I'm so good.
It's a good la west coast,
not la,
not la.
And then there's that one.
Shit.
That's really funny.
Uh,
so thanks Caleb.
And thanks for a lot of people who have like the mugs.
Couple of mugs are in the store now.
Uh,
some,
excuse me.
Sign Items and shirts.
Go ahead.
Try it out.
Um,
I think that's a gene.
Anything else?
No,
I love you.
Here is a,
what is this trash boy.
Bye Nick.
See,
um,
thanks guys and we'll see you next week.
Okay.
[inaudible] how
are you?
What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun?